[Music]
all right Fox Business Prime is back
with new seasons of great Prime Time
shows like American built American
Dynasty Kelsey grammer's historical uh
historic battles for America and how
America Works hosted by our good friend
Mike Rowe and just like last season he's
going to be taking you behind the scenes
for an in-depth look at the people to
keep this country running the people
that make the country great here is a
sneak peek of the first episode of the
new season which focuses on the men and
women who keep America's cargo moving
think about life without them not pretty
instead of me being down here picking up
little by little half buckets or quarter
buckets he rolls it all down here into
the big piles where I can grab full
buckets each time and it will save us
time and in
[Music]
everything's going good right now it's
going smooth
but as Johnny's about to find out
his troubles with the hopper aren't over
yet go ahead
you're kidding right all right here now
with more is our friend and the host of
how America works it airs Monday nights
at 8pm on our sister Network the Fox
Business Network Mike Rose with us you
know going back to your days of you know
I just love how you
you know if he doesn't even he doesn't
even have to talk
very cool uh I told you you have the
only other job I would want in TV with
the two shows that you had now the third
show that you have with us with Fox
Business and that is Dirty Jobs and
Deadliest Catch
um and and I love all of it
I don't think Americans truly appreciate
what it takes to get those uh big crab
legs that they like to eat at a
restaurant I don't think they know uh
what it takes to manufacture something I
don't think we fully understand the
impact of what farmers do for us every
day and ranchers do for us every day and
in this particular case you know getting
um you know getting everything packed
and moved and off of ships and out to
stores I don't think we really realize
do you think America is appreciate it
well they're two different things
realization and appreciation most of us
have never really realized it but we've
always intuitively appreciate it we know
that when we flick the switch and the
light comes on that that's the result of
a miracle and that Miracle is made
possible by men and women doing things
out of sight and out of mind what I
worry about is the overall lack of
appreciation that has infected in my
view our society over the last 30 or 40
years my TV shows the two that you
mentioned as well as how America works
are just an attempt to tap the country
on the shoulder and say hey look if we
don't hang on to this fundamental
appreciation for the kinds of jobs that
make civilized life possible for the
rest of us we're going to have a list of
unintended consequences longer than your
arm
did covid change that in some ways did
we get a greater appreciation for uh
people that work in the medical field
you know everybody from doctors and
nurses and orderlies and and everybody
in between uh did we get a greater
appreciation for the truck drivers uh if
they weren't Trucking and Packers
weren't packing and Farmers weren't
farming uh we wouldn't have survived do
you think people now have a little bit
of a increased appreciation
I hate to paint with two broader brush I
know I do I know that the whole Zoom
world the conversation we're having
right now three years ago that that
didn't happen I came to New York I sat
in the studio with you this is made
possible by fiber optics and Men driving
around at all hours making sure
everything is connected so I think in a
lot of ways covet gave us a wake-up call
but I'm afraid it did something else too
Sean honestly I know I'm a broken record
on this but I was listening to Joe
Concha a couple segments back go down
the list of things that are important to
voters and I'll tell you what nobody's
talking about no one is talking about
the 7 million able-bodied men who are
not only unemployed today but who have
affirmatively left the workforce I just
spent an hour and a half interviewing a
guy named Nick everstadt brilliant
Economist who who believes that that
statistic far more so than unemployment
numbers and really any other metric is
the thing that should scare the hell out
of us that number of evil able-bodied
men combined with the 11 million jobs
that are currently open that's never
happened in our country before and if we
don't fix that we're on that part of the
map where it says here be dragons
because we don't know what's coming next
micro always love having you and I love
all of your shows we'll be watching on
Monday thanks for being with us hey
don't forget tune in to Mike Rose how
America works it's on a sister network
Fox Business Monday night you don't want
to miss it